I want to teach you a trick that will
help you identify if you have an
electron-withdrawing group or an
electron donating group on your molecule
in this lesson we're going to focus on
electrophilic aromatic substitution
because the presence of electron
withdrawing and electron donating groups
can change the reactivity of the
molecule when a benzene ring with an
electron withdrawing group reacts with
an electrophile in electrophilic
aromatic substitution the electrophile
adds to the meta position from this EAS
reaction with the electron donating
group we get introduction of the new
electro file or so and para to the
electron donating group so we can say
that these electron withdrawing groups
are meta directors and donating groups
are ortho-para directors now electron
withdrawing groups are just how they
sound they pull electrons out of the
ring and so electron withdrawing groups
actually make it harder for the ring to
undergo EAS the electrons are being
pulled up toward this electron
withdrawing group out of the ring and so
it's less reactive we therefore say that
these rings with electron withdrawing
groups are deactivated
conversely these electron donating
groups have electrons that can donate
into the ring either through resonance
or an inductive effect because of the
added electron density on rings
containing electron donating groups we
say that electron donating groups are
activating groups this is because the
ring is more likely to undergo
electrophilic aromatic substitution when
an EDG is present on the ring okay now
let's get into our trick to figure out
if we have a donating or withdrawing
group say we have a substituted aromatic
ring we have groups bonded to it Y is
directly bonded to the Ring and Z is
directly bonded to Y okay if Z is more
electronegative than Y this is an
electron withdrawing group and if
I is the more electronegative element
then it's an electron donating group now
this trick is going to work for most
groups that will see substituting
aromatic rings but we need to add in
just one more caveat to the rule just to
make it work all the time and this
happens when y is positively charged if
Y has a formal positive charge then this
is also an electron withdrawing group
let's quickly review electronegativity
in the corner of the periodic table so
we can deal with most of the elements
that we'll encounter in our examples
going across the table we have carbon
than nitrogen oxygen fluorine I've given
a silly acronym before can normal owl
fly - remember that piece going down
from fluorine are the rest of the
halogens and let's just add in the two
elements below nitrogen and oxygen that
we may see in our organic compounds
electronegativity is going to increase
on a diagonal going up toward fluorine
and fluorine is the most electronegative
element let's take a few examples will
apply the trick but then we'll actually
look at resonance forms and the
chemistry to see why our trick works so
well okay so here are our examples we
have a nitrile a methoxy group a ketone
and an amide let's apply our trick to
problem a bonded directly to the ring we
have carbon carbon is bonded to nitrogen
which is to the right of it on our
periodic table so carbon is bonded to
something more electronegative than
itself and this is an electron
withdrawing group it'll be a meta
director and deactivate the ring we can
also explain this with resonance the
nitrile is conjugated with the double
bonds in the ring so we can draw
resonance forms that pull electron
density out of the ring so we moved our
electrons away from this carbon atom so
it gets our positive charge and we push
electrons up onto nitrogen and it's
stabilizing our negative charge
continuing to push electrons around the
ring we get a positive charge at the
para position and we can draw a final
resonance form where the positive
charges or so
in electrophilic aromatic substitution
one of the double bonds in benzene has
to open up and attack an electrophile
electrophiles are positive now a
positive charge doesn't want to interact
with another positive charge and so the
increased electro positivity of the
ortho and para positions when an
electron withdrawing group is on the
ring prevent it from reacting there and
that's why this is a meta director okay
let's check out problem B we have an
oxygen directly bonded to the ring and
mass bonded to carbon a less
electronegative element so this is an
electron donating group oxygen can be
inductively electron withdrawing due to
its electronegativity however it has
lone pairs that are in conjugation with
the ring we can actually push them into
the ring and increase the electron
density within this aromatic ring
resonance is typically stronger than
induction and so the electron donating
resonance beats out the inductive effect
so using this lone pair to push
electrons in the ring we get a negative
charge at our ortho position if we
continue to push electrons around the
ring we'll see we get concentration of
electron density at the para and the
ortho positions so it makes sense that
these electron donating groups would be
ortho-para directors when they go to
react with a positive electrophile they
want to react in the positions with
greater electron density let's check out
our ketone here's a carbon directly
bonded to the ring and mass bonded to an
oxygen a more electronegative element
this is an electron withdrawing group
again we have conjugation with the
double bonds in the ring so we can draw
resonance forms that pull the electrons
directly out of the ring and into the
ketone here's our first resonance form
and we could continue to push electrons
around the ring just like in our first
example and see that positive charge is
concentrated on the ortho and para
positions in our final example we have
nitrogen directly bonded the ring and
it's bonded to a carbon atom this is an
electron donating group because nitrogen
is our more electronegative element and
nitrogen has lone pairs it can donate
into the ring so just like with example
B we can push these electrons in and
push the negative charge up onto carbon
again for this example we could draw two
more resonance forms pushing this
negative charge around the ring and see
that it's concentrated on the ortho and
para positions now this is kind of an
interesting case we have this electron
donation into the ring but electron
density can also be pulled in the other
direction by the carbonyl let's just
look at that for a second so instead if
we push toward the carbonyl
we'll pull electrons away from the ring
now this structure contributes and this
structure also contributes so this is
still an electron donating group our
trick still works but it is not as
powerful of an electron donating group
as we saw an example be with our methoxy
the overall power that an electron
donating or withdrawing group has is
also important to its reactivity so
we'll discuss the strength of electron
withdrawing and electron donating groups
in another lesson KP here if you learn
something give me a thumbs up on the way
out and for more chemistry subscribe to
my channel